[music]
yeah yeah yeah 7 oh dare haha ​​good
me
[music]
ipa
ha
yeah yeah yeah I got it
[music]
Pane Falls
You're a beast who doesn't really like science
, right
?
I'm a needle
serval around here Hmm, then those ears and tails
And something unusual
You're friends
without tails and ears
Unusual friends Where did you come from Hey
[music]
I understand
I don't remember
Before I knew it, I entered here
Ah, I wonder if the child was born on the mountain trail yesterday
Sand Star
Yes, it erupted from that mountain yesterday
.
If there's something, I'll try it, but I'll take
a peek.
Thank you, Balsa
, where should I go to the library?
Mmm
[music]
Debut is fine
I'm saying meow
What is Serval's territorial territory?
It's a similar label channel I
understand The
savannah region is wide
[music] The
author bar likes the jungle temperature
, so it reflects even the savannah's mouth
Is the exit quite far away?
Gender
5 a
Ehime
No,
no, no,
slow, lan, child machine,
maybe you're a lazy friend or
something?
It's
called Cerulean It's a
bit dangerous, so be careful
But if it's that size, I'll beat it with my proud claws
Wow, that's amazing,
Mr. Serval
I have that kind of power
This is how I feel
when I'm just
being
sweet,
Satou.  I know I'm good at it,
but it's written kyun The sun is the best when it's wet, so you can't move
[music]
Later, there's no more water.
I wish I could fly away from education My
friends
Do you have a lot of
things?  Oh
, but be careful with the cerulean I mentioned earlier.
Actually, there shouldn't be many around here,
but Mr. Serval's claws were
amazing. It's
Plains' technique
.  Hey,
I'm getting
better, too. It's amazing I walked quite a bit, and I think I'm good
.
I live in an area
where a little grass grows, so it's
easy to walk in that kind of place
.
I like animals that can
jump easily, so I like high places, so it's easy for
one person to jump with noodles
.
If
you can climb a tree, it's convenient for
you to
escape at midnight.
[Music]
There's a water bar over there Cutter oh
oh oh oh oh
this
th
Bach
[Music]
dea
eme
terun hi
ca eem
I've done 9 things here.
[Music]
Excuse me, I was
bathing.
So everyone
, it's not
too big, but there's a little big one at the gate, so be
careful.
I don't know what kind of animal it is,
so why don't you go to the library?
[MUSIC]
You
can swim No, you can fly  But
it's all messed up with carelessness
There are children, so there's nothing to worry about It
's terrible, I can't swim either.
You ca
n't leave it up to Serval Okay,
come on, we're cats,
basically, if you're with Cerulean, you'll run away.
I'm not sweating right
now Mizumoto Kusan
tan
It's the gate in a
minute
.
Is it true
you know where
Tifa is?
What's up
Balsa
[Music]
Is that Cerulean too?
Ahhh
[applause]
[music]
ah ah ah
You painted me a big firefighter and read the sutras,
didn't
you?  I tried to help you
Servicer
Good
ah ah
[music]
Incision
Earlier Garial The
flying
one What did you do and how did you
do it I made a paper plane
If I say so, the children from the Plains
should be able to judge me to the next region.
Thank you very
much
.
If you
understand,
I
'll be in the Savannah again I'll definitely
do that Next time we meet, read it with Sabae-chanSpeak more normally I'm already a friend
Hoop,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
yeah  I
wonder if it's
okay because we broke up
I
'm looking forward to a big river
today,
Serval-chan, how
are
you doing?
Hey, ah [music] I'm an acquaintance
Boss this book I don't know what kind of animal it is
I'll guide you to where you live
Nice to meet you I'm Lucky Reese Nice to meet you Nice to meet you I'm
Kaban No matter what Sabo-chan
[  [music]
before
[music]
aniani
me
ah ah ah
[music]
me
ah ah ah
[music]
rar It seems like I'm going to school I need to
catch it quickly
It
's a long way to
go.  Hey, what does God in the heavens mean?